hi guys sci-fi recap here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2021 american fantasy and adventure
movie called jungle cruise
the movie begins with an explanation
about the legend of the tears of the
moon from amazon they are petals from a
magic tree that could cure any illness
and break any curse in the mid 16th
century spanish conquistadors led by
agira undertake an expedition to amazon
forest to seek the tree out and possess
the tears power however they were beaten
by the power of nature causing the
journey to end in failure the legend
states that aguero was saved by local
villagers despite the kindness that was
given the greedy agira attacked them
forcing the chief to hand over the
sacred arrowhead but later condemned to
be a prisoner of the jungle
in 1916 mcgregor explains to the royal
society of explorers that tears of the
moon is not a myth and can be used for
medical purposes
thus he requests access to the ancient
arrowhead that was recently recovered
but the group rejects his request saying
that it is just a waste of time while
mcgregor keeps trying to convince the
group his sister lily leaves the hall
and sneaks into the archive room she
manages to dodge and distract the people
inside that room and eventually comes
across a crate containing the sacred
arrowhead which will be the key to find
the tears of the moon prince joachim who
is also seeking for the arrowhead
discovers that it has been stolen and
spots lily he immediately orders the
others to capture her
she attempts to escape on a ladder and
knocks everyone out however joachim
manages to hit the ladder causing lily
to hang off at the edge of the ladder
luckily mcgregor sees her and stops a
bus letting her drop and both of them
manage to escape with the arrowhead on
the other side a curator accidentally
reveals joachim's identity to others he
gets angry and starts to eliminate
everyone in the room
lily and mcgregor prepare themselves to
go to amazon to find the tears of the
moon the scene moves to south america
where a skipper called frank is taking a
group of rich people on a ride across
the amazon river on his old boat laquila
he has set up a bunch of cheap tricks to
entertain the passengers but they don't
seem interested in that as they are
frightened every time he performs the
tricks
he also engages in many lame puns which
confuse the passengers because of that
even one of the passengers is willing to
pay him a lot of money only to make the
boat go faster
long story short lily and mcgregor
arrive in south america to seek out nilo
a harbour master that will provide them
a boat for the expedition
turns out that franco's nilo money and
he decides to take out frank boat's
engine until he pays the debt frank
secretly follows him and sneaks into his
office to get his engine back
in the meantime
while mcgregor goes around the bar lily
arrives at neila's office and meets
frank who disguises himself as nilo she
helps him to retrieve his boat key and
frank somehow manages to convince her to
hire him for the expedition to the tree
they almost come to an agreement until
mcgregor appears with a real nilo lily
has lost her trust in the skipper and
when she is about to leave suddenly a
wild jaguar appears and starts
terrorizing people in the bar
frank decides to fight the jaguar and
manages to take him out of the bar with
a piece of meat
this action then convinces lily and
mcgregor to hire him for the expedition
as frank reclaims his engine he reveals
that the jaguar proxima is frank's pet
and he deliberately ordered proxima to
make a scene at the bar while frank and
mcgregor are debating about the luggages
lily is kidnapped by bird poachers hired
by joachim luckily she is a professional
lock picker and manages to free herself
from the cage
frank comes to help her and they run
towards the boat as joachim's henchmen
chase after them
long story short after a long and
exhausting chase lily frank and mcgregor
regroup on la cuela and the journey to
the tree begins
realizing that lily escaped from his
men's grasp the german emerges from his
submarine and starts firing at them with
a machine gun causing the boat to lose
power and force frank to move the boat
manually he even launches a torpedo at
them but frank manages to drive the boat
through an old building as the torpedo
passes under them they eventually run
away from joachim while the submarine
gets stuck and hits nila's other boats
on their way frank tries to get closer
to the siblings by telling his cheap
jokes
lily also introduces a moving picture
camera to the skipper they decide to
stop to rest while frank serves them
freshly fried piranhas for dinner later
that night lily and mcgregor figure out
that proxima is frank's pet this fact
makes lily very upset and loses her
trust again on the other side joachim
and his men head over to an underground
cavern where agira and his men were
imprisoned joachim drips river water
which awakens agira who currently
possesses snakes within his body he
agrees to help the german to seek out
the tears of the moon because it's the
only way to break the curse
with a detonator joachim floods the
cavern with river water to reawaken the
remaining conquistadors
the next day thanks to the route lily
chose earlier they come across rough
water and nearly fall down to a huge
waterfall
luckily frank is a skillful boat driver
and manages to get them on the other
path to safety they pull over to the
land and stop for a moment while cutting
down trees mcgregor implicitly reveals
to frank that he was disowned by his
family because he is gay he adds that
lily was always there for him supporting
him that's why he is willing to follow
her wherever she goes
lily sneaks into frank's room where she
discovers that he is a big fan of
automobiles and finds several maps of
the magic tree upon the men returning to
the boat lily immediately accuses frank
telling him that he's after the tears of
the moon for himself
he then tells her that he has given up
on that plan for a very long time
because he always failed a few moments
later they are knocked out by darts
they are captured by locals and are
brought to a native tribe the chieftain
who speaks in tupi language requests
lily to give them back the arrowhead
lily insists and refuses to give it up
she then manages to break free in
attempts to escape
however sam reveals that the scene has
been set up by frank
lily is infuriated with his constant
deception and punches him
later lily talks to sam who helps her to
translate the writing in the arrowhead
she informs her the exact location of
the tree and explains that the tree only
blooms under a blood moon which occurs
in two days
suddenly agira and his men with their
disgusting appearance appear at the
tribe and start attacking people it
seems like agira and frank know each
other the skipper and lily attempt to
escape through a rope but they fail
after a rough fight the conquistadors
managed to get the arrowhead but frank
retrieves it and throws it back to lily
while he gets stabbed by aguirre's blade
and falls down to the water
lily escapes and is told to get away
from the river the conquistadors have to
pull back since the curse prevents them
from going beyond the river they then
send a message to joachim by using the
bees the next day lily is shocked when
he finds out that frank is alive with
the blade still stabbed in his chest he
then reveals that his real name is
francisco and he is roughly 400 years
old
lily helps him to pull the blade out of
his chest
frank and lily continue their journey
themselves while mcgregor stays behind
with sam since he is injured
frank shares his past story to the woman
he and nagira had grown up together like
brothers at some point aguirre's
daughter had fallen ill and he sought
out the tears of the moon to cure her
where frank was assigned as the
cartographer
however they were beaten by nature and
agira lost most of his men the remaining
men refused to turn back and later they
were found by the villagers who used the
petals of the tree to heal them however
agira became impatient and forced the
chieftain to give him the arrowhead the
chieftain refused as he wasn't worthy
enough so aguirre killed him
frank then helped the chief's daughter
to secure the arrowhead before the
chieftain died he cursed aguirre and his
men to be bound to the jungle and never
be able to leave
agira hated frank for betraying him
since then they repeatedly fight with
each other until frank set up a trap to
lure aguero and his men into a cavern
away from the river keeping them trapped
there for centuries
after that frank built a town and got
closer with nearby villagers he then
reveals that he has been searching for
the tears of the moon so he can die
peacefully in his submarine the bees
inform the prince lily's location and he
immediately orders his men to change
course
long story short the submarine manages
to reach the informed location and find
sam and mcgregor joachim takes lily's
brother with him while the tribe leader
swims away he forces mcgregor to lead
them to lily's current location
on the other side the boat eventually
arrives at la luna rota the real
location of the tears of the moon
lily must overcome her fear of swimming
because she is needed to help frank to
pull a lever that will open a chamber
since his body is too huge
after several attempts and almost losing
her breath she manages to pull it down
and the river water suddenly recedes
unfortunately joachim and mcgregor have
been waiting for them under the water
joachim forces them to enter the passage
and lily is forced to hand over the
arrowhead the german explains that he
will use the petals to win the war
they finally arrive at the tree and the
prince orders lily and frank to activate
the magic tree they realize that the
arrowhead is meant to be a heart and
eventually discover a red gem hidden in
it under the blood moon lily puts the
gem into the broken-hearted warrior
figure and the tree starts to bloom
because only one of them will receive
the petal lily deliberately shoots frank
and after that they walk towards the
petals the immortal frank returns to the
boat and eliminates joachim's men while
lily outsmarts you okay and runs towards
the petals alone before time's up
she manages to secure a pedal and hands
it over to frank
suddenly the conquistadors join the
chaos and nagira immediately attacks
joachim with snakes for betraying him
frank hands over the pedal to mcgregor
and then engages in a fight with the
gear and his men on the boat the skipper
purposely steers the boat toward a wall
to block the river a while joachim
appears but this time mcgregor punches
him in the face causing him to be killed
by a falling pillar the boat crashes
into the wall stopping the water from
flowing and permanently imprisoning
agira his men and frank
lilly decides to give the pedal to frank
it doesn't appear to work at first but
proxima roars as she sees that the stone
around frank crumbles
frank is brought back to life but
without immortality
lily immediately runs towards him and
hugs the annoying skipper the trio
safely arrive at the harbor and return
to london
at the end of the movie mcgregor rejects
the invitation of membership from the
royal society while lilly buys frank has
long awaited automobile
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching